elisabeth lag im bett als die flammen um
sie schlugen die polizei glaubte damals
dass elisabeth diesen brand selbst
verursacht hat das kann nicht sein
sagten ihre eltern und sie hatten recht
jetzt ja die polizei lisa bettany mörder
in der cold case elisabeth schmidt ein
kriminalfall der als unfall beginnt
elisabeth schmidt kommt nämlich nach
einer langen schicht im krankenhaus nach
hause geht ins bett sie schläft ein und
plötzlich steht die wohnung in flammen
die feuerwehr kann später nur noch den
tod feststellen und notiert als
wahrscheinliche todesursache
rauchen im bett doch es gibt zwei
menschen karin und dietmar schmidt die
eltern von elisabeth die ihre tochter
besser kennen sie wissen ihre elisabeth
die hat nie im bett geraucht sie kann
diesen brand also gar nicht selbst
verursacht haben und die eltern sollten
recht behalten der unfall dieser
mitschnitt ist nämlich in wahrheit ein
mordfall thilo scholtyssek mit den
recherchen
elisabeth schmidt 26 jahre eine junge
frau gerade frisch verlobt mit dem
wunsch nach eigenen kindern und einer
klaren vorstellung vom leben als
angehende krankenschwester wollte sie
menschen helfen ein video zeigt sie mit
ihrer damals besten freundin
[Musik]
elisabeth ist fröhlich unbeschwert
voller tatendrang mit träumen hoffnungen
zukunftsplänen sie wollte heiraten mit
ihrem freund zusammenziehen die
gemeinsame wohnung ausbauen
den tod ihrer freundin kann michaela war
da bis heute nur schwer ertragen
es schwer zu erklären aber das gibt es
hier an der eigenen bild nicht so was
passiert im fernsehen oder weit weg
[Musik]
und ich verstehe das auch immer noch
nicht
man hatte schon genug damit zu tun was
sie nicht mehr da als
vor zehn jahren erfahren ihre eltern vom
tod ihrer tochter dass ihr kind nicht
opfer eines tragischen unglücks sondern
eines verbrechens wurde
ich möchte schon gerne wissen warum
auch auf so eine art und weise ja
[Musik]
wenn ich das sehe ich zwar alles
gezielte stiche
im jahr 2011 berichten bild chefreporter
thilo scholtyseck und seine kollegen
anfangs über einen tragischen
unglücksfall eine nachricht eine kleine
randnotiz bis sich herausstellt dass
elisabeth schmidt in diesem haus
ermordet und verbrannt wurde
braut verbrennt im schlafzimmer
dieses feuer sollte einen mord
vertuschen
kannte diese krankenschwester ihren
mörder doch wie kann es sein dass ihre
mutter seit mehr als zehn jahren
unbehelligt weiter lebt
und wann überbringen die ermittler ihren
eltern endlich die erlösende nachricht
dass der täter gefasst
[Musik]
bild chefreporter thilo scholtyseck geht
für achtung fahndung erneut auf
spurensuche trifft ermittler und
elisabeths eltern zehn jahre nach der
ermordung ihrer tochter
der täter wenn er verurteilt würde dann
könnten wir zur ruhe kommen jeden tag
ist das für uns aktuell ja das ist immer
schön wenn man irgendwas macht wenn es
etwas in die hände
feierabend kann ich nicht mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
goslar in niedersachsen am harz die
asklepios harzkliniken macht elisabeth
schmidt eine ausbildung zur
krankenschwester
die 26 jährige hat gerade mit dem
dritten lehrjahr begonnen
es ist der 13 dezember 2011 elisabeth
schmidt hat an diesem abend spätschicht
im krankenhaus
die fakten die feststehenden sind das
elisabeth gehen 22 45 am abend des 13 12
2010 das krankenhaus nach ihrer spät
verlassen hat dort unten in dem bereich
noch auf eine kollegin getroffen dass
beide dann über den parkplatz gegangen
sind und die dann in sein auto gestiegen
ist dann haben wir leider eine
zeitspanne die wir bis zum heutigen tag
nicht rekonstruieren konnten wo
elisabeth dann im anschluss hingefahren
ist
was geschah zwischen 22 45 und 4 uhr
morgens
war elisabeth an diesem abend noch im
wenige kilometer entfernten
schwesternwohnheim wo sie während ihrer
ausbildung ein zimmer hatte fest steht
nur in dieser nacht fährt die 26-jährige
irgendwann mit ihrem wagen einem citroën
saxo von goslar vermutlich über die
damalige b6 die rund 60 kilometer zum
ruhen und elternhaus ihres freundes in
thale
wir wissen dass das fahrzeug dann am
morgen des 14 12 2011 gegen 4 uhr in
thale stand man in dieser welt dort
eingetroffen ist dass wir bis zum
heutigen zeitpunkt leider nicht
seit einem jahr ist elizabeth mit ihrem
freund zusammen vor zwei wochen haben
sie sich verlobt wollten heiraten
zusammenziehen
an diesem abend ist sie zum ersten mal
alleine in der wohnung ihres freundes er
ist auf nachtschicht in einer brauerei
in wernigerode
elisabeth wollte in der wohnung warten
bis er nach hause kommt was in dieser
zeit geschieht ist bis heute unklar
zwischen drei und vier uhr nachts bricht
in der wohnung ein feuer aus
ein großeinsatz für die feuerwehren aus
der umgebung
nach spätere rekonstruktion ist der
brand in der nähe des bettes
ausgebrochen
hier findet man später auch den leichnam
von elisabeth die brand ermittler gehen
davon aus dass sie im bett geraucht hat
und eingeschlafen ist
[Musik]
die kollegen die als erste vor ort
eingetroffen sind haben die feuerwehr
vorgefunden die dabei war den brand zu
löschen und sind nach erster
inaugenscheinnahme des brandortes davon
ausgegangen dass hier ein brandgeschehen
stattgefunden hat im zuge der obduktion
der elisabeth schmid wurde dann
festgestellt dass in dieser welt bei
ausbruch des brandes bereits tot war das
problem da man anfänglich von
eigenverschulden ausgeht hat die
obduktion von elisabeths leiche keine
priorität erst eine woche später bei
einer routine untersuchung in der
gerichtsmedizin in magdeburg stellen
rechtsmediziner fest dass sich in
elisabeths blut weder kohlenmonoxid noch
rußablagerungen im mund und
rachenbereich befinden für experten der
beweis sie hat nicht mehr geliebt als
das feuer ausgebrochen ist bei einer
genaueren untersuchung ihres leichnams
entdecken die rechtsmediziner zu den
stichverletzungen im nacken und
rückenbereich ab diesem zeitpunkt steht
fest elisabeth schmid wurde ermordet das
feuer sollte die spuren eines
gewaltverbrechens vertuschen gottes hat
man zeichen die man am ersten tag auch
hätte erkennen können nicht gesehen so
war die lage der leiche sehr auffällig
sie lag nicht normal im bett sondern
nach quer über das bett ende
und sie wussten dass eine raucherin aber
sie wussten nicht wie ihre eltern die
familie das wusste dass sie nie im bett
geraucht hätte ja die falsche annahme
dass in dieser patch mit im bett
geraucht hat hat den ganzen fall in eine
völlig falsche spur gebracht
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt gehen auch
elisabeths eltern davon aus dass ihre
tochter opfer eines tragischen
unglücksfalls wurde sie sind gerade mit
dem auto unterwegs als sie aus dem radio
erfahren dass ihre tochter ermordet
wurde
[Musik]
die information ist an die medien
durchgesickert bevor die eltern
informiert werden konnten das eine welt
zusammengebrochen
das war unbegreiflich
unbegreiflich wer macht so was und wer
warum sind die frauen thema immer wieder
und das ist heute noch genau wie damals
in der nacht zum 14 dezember 2011 wird
die feuerwehr zu einem brand in einem
haus in sachsen anhaltinischen thale
gerufen
in der wohnung finden die ermittler eine
tote frau
zunächst geht man davon aus dass der
brand selbst verschuldet ist elisabeth
schmidt opfer eines tragischen unglücks
wurde
erst nach einer obduktion wird klar es
war mord
bevor die junge frau verbrannt ist wurde
sie mit mehreren messerstichen getötet
wie so häufig hatte elisabeth an diesem
abend ihre anziehsachen für den nächsten
tag im badezimmer bereitgelegt als ihr
leichnam gefunden wird hatte sie bereits
ihre schlafsachen an
das bestätigt auch ihr damaliger freund
2013 in der mdr sendung kripo live
[Musik]
ich habe die sowjets kleidung gefunden
im schlafzimmer sowie im badezimmer
sowie es immer gemacht wenn sie sich
abends ausgezogen hat für mich ist sie
ganz normal ins bett gegangen wie immer
kam der täter als sich elisabeth in der
wohnung aufhielt das fenster war sie
womöglich gut zu erkennen wurde sie von
jemandem beobachtet einbruchspuren
konnten nicht festgestellt werden
gestohlen wurde nichts kannte die 26
jährige möglicherweise ihren mörder hat
sie ihm arglos geöffnet diese
möglichkeiten haben wir auch in betracht
gezogen haben auch mit den betroffenen
gesprochen
aus dem engeren umfeld
und
sind eben zu dem schluss gekommen dass
wir stand jetzt nicht wissen wie der
oder die täter in das haus gekommen sind
elizabeths verlobter hatte eine wohnung
im haus seiner eltern elisabeth war an
diesem abend zum ersten mal alleine in
seiner wohnung
so schildert es ihr damaliger freund
2013 in einem interview mit der mdr
sendung kripo live
du musst du jemand davon überhaupt dass
dieser ort verabredet hatten nein gar
nicht
ich weiß nicht mehr ob es neben bei
meinen eltern gegenüber erwähnt hatte
aber auch meine eltern hätte es niemand
wissen können und wie war das gerät mit
dem schlüssel dann müssten ja auch
darüber gesprochen haben sie hatte ihren
eigenen fassung
[Musik]
elisabeth schwiegereltern leben im
erdgeschoss zum zeitpunkt als das feuer
ausbricht sind sie zu hause
der schwiegervater gerät in verdacht
denn als ihn seine frau in dieser nacht
auf brandgeruch hinweist soll er
abgewickelt haben seine frau sogar
aufgefordert haben sich wieder hin zu
leben nachdem dann feststand dass es ein
verbrechen ist er hat die polizei
natürlich zuerst im nahbereich ermittelt
und kam dann auf den verdacht dass der
schwiegervater vielleicht etwas mit dem
tod von elizabeth zu tun haben könnte
die polizei hat in langen vernommen ist
aber nicht wirklich weitergekommen einen
tatverdacht gegen ihn konnte nicht
erwartet werden
bei tötungsdelikten prüft die polizei
immer das nächste umfeld der opfer
nichts ungewöhnliches auch elisabeth
verlobter gerät in den fokus der
ermittlungen da er sich zum tatzeitpunkt
aber nachweislich auf nachtschicht in
einer brauerei in wernigerode aufhielt
ergibt sich auch hier kein verdacht
kennengelernt haben er und elisabeth
sich auf einer singlebörse im internet
schwarzes glück eine internetplattform
für anhänger der gothic und dark wave
szene
und eine vorliebe für morbide
selbstdarstellungen stammt elisabeth
mörder aus dieser szene die wahl auf
konzerten war natürlich auch bei partys
die haben sich blutverschmiert in szene
gesetzt fotos und dergleichen da hat die
polizei natürlich auch gesucht geforscht
ermittelt aber es hat sich da auch kein
tatverdacht gegen eine konkrete person
erhalten lassen
in ihren social media accounts erinnert
elizabeth ihren status in verlobt war
jemand damit nicht einverstanden
war jemand eifersüchtig
doch alle spuren alle ermittlungsansätze
führen ins nichts
rafal elisabeth schmidt wird zum code
case
[Musik]
das nach all den jahren niemand für die
schreckliche tat verantwortlich gemacht
werden konnte die frage nach dem warum
nicht beantwortet wird ist neben dem
verlust ihrer tochter das schlimmste für
elisabeth eltern
da ist elisabeth
zugedeckt mit na
ja es ist einfach schrecklich jetzt
apfel friedlich ich habe auch geglaubt
das könnte einmal weniger wird jetzt
aber er wird anders er wird an das ist
jetzt immer
teilweise schlimmer sie fehlt uns und
das zweite ist eben dass der täter nicht
ermittelt wurde das ist das was uns auch
noch mal
ja nahezu täglich ins loch gibt ja
bild chefreporter thilo scholtyseck
trifft michaela wada die heute 40
jährige war mit elisabeth eng befreundet
gemeinsam haben sie ihre ausbildung
angefangen
sie lebten tür an tür in diesem
schwesternwohnheim in goslar
und wenn man die augen zumacht dann
erlebt man halt auch die einzelnen
situation schöne situation
die man hier aus dem boden heraus
gegangen ist und zum unterricht gegangen
ist so in dieser schmerz dieser innere
leere da muss man alleine durch weil
sicherlich hat drin man und man hat
kippen aber man hat nicht mehr die
freundin
mit der man alles teil
bis heute beschäftigen angehörige
freunde und ermittler folgende frage wo
und wann ist elisabeth in dieser nacht
auf ihren mörder getroffen
konnte sie den täter oder war er ein
fremder vor allem der zeitpunkt vom
verlassen der klinik um 22 uhr 45 in
goslar bis zu elisabeths ankunft am haus
ihres verlobten in thale ist für die
ermittler bis heute ein schwarzes loch
der fahndungs schwerpunkt liegt
sicherlich auf jeden fall darauf zu
erfahren was hat elisabeth nach ihrer
arbeit gemacht es ist nach verlassen des
krankenhauses 22045 in goslar
wo es sie dorthin gefahren ist sie
direkt natale gefallen hat irgendjemand
sie unterwegs gesehen ist das auto
aufgefallen weiß jemand ob sie sich
getroffen hat mit einer anderen person
diese dinge sind für uns wichtig weil
dieses zeitfenster bisher für uns noch
nicht nachvollziehbar ist
die ermittler wissen nicht ob elizabeth
nach ende ihrer spätschicht im
krankenhaus um 22.45 noch ins wenige
kilometer entfernte schwesternwohnheim
in goslar gefahren ist bzw auf direktem
weg ins 60 kilometer entfernte thale es
gibt zwei strecken die elisabeth
genommen haben könnte beide führen über
die ehemalige b 6 heute a 36
vermutlich ist sie über blankenburg oder
timmenrode weiter über die l 92 nach
thale gefahren
besonders auffällig erwarten ein citroën
saxo
kennzeichen mansfelder land die
zahlreichen aufklebern an der fahrer-
und beifahrerseite
zudem will die polizei magdeburg rissen
hat jemand gesehen weil sie in thale
eingetroffen ist hat jemand das fahrzeug
in thale gesehen hat jemand mitbekommen
wie sie vor der tür dort abgepackt hat
diese dinge waren für uns sehr sehr
wichtig um dann weitere ermittlungen
führen zu können
bitte melden sie sich bei der polizei in
magdeburg denn jeder hinweis jede
zeugenaussage jeder in
kann zur lösung des falls beitragen
und damit den angehörigen eltern und
freunden endlich die gewissheit geben
wer für den tod von elisabeth schmitt
verantwortlich ist
[Musik]
ja und über diesen fall wollen wir
weiter sprechen mit dr constantinis die
bei uns ist rechtsmedizinerin von der
uniklinik frankfurt guten abend
wir haben es ja gerade gehört der
vermeintliche unfall hat sich als
mordfall herausgestellt und zwar erst
nachdem die leiche in der rechtsmedizin
untersucht wurde was genau war denn das
von der untersuchung und findet die bei
jedem unfall statt ja es ist so bei
sterbefällen wo man anhaltspunkte für
einen nicht natürlichen tod hat zum
beispiel ein brand wird die leiche
beschlagnahmt und es wird ein
todesermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet
und im rahmen dieses verfahrens wo die
todesumstände geklärt werden sollen wird
eine gerichtliche leichen eröffnung
angeordnet das ist eine richterliche
sache mit beschluss und letztendlich ist
das eine routineuntersuchung also die
gerichtliche leisen öffnung die dann ja
möglichst die beweise sichern soll und
verschiedene fragen beantworten soll wie
genau finden dann die experten finden
experten wie sie heraus dass der mensch
der dort liegt vor dem brand getötet
wurde und nicht durch den brand
gestorben ist ja wir suchen nach den
sogenannten vitalen zeichen also
hinweise am körper die belegen können
dass die person zum zeitpunkt des
brandausbruches noch gelebt hat
üblicherweise seien bericht auch
aufgeführt worden verschlucken die ruß
und sie atmen russ 1 und vor allem
atmete brandgase ein das heißt man hat
mir kohlenmonoxid intoxikation oder das
kohlenmonoxid kann entsprechend dann
nachgewiesen werden bei der
blutuntersuchung das wäre dann auch die
todesursache
wenn all das vorliegt dann ist für uns
bewiesen dass die person zum zeitpunkt
des brandausbruches noch gelebt hat und
das heißt also dass der brand dann auch
die todesursache gewesen ist sie haben
uns einen knochen mitgebracht der auch
eine verletzung aufweist weil was wir
uns gefragt haben ist wie kann man denn
an einer brand leiche eine frau die im
bett gelegen hat die ganze wohnung hat
gebebt wie kann man da überhaupt noch
herausfinden dass da stichverletzungen
vorgelegen haben vielleicht können sie
uns das einmal an diesem knochen zeigen
denn der frau sie haben erzählt vorhin
im vorgespräch ist auch was ähnliches
passiert genau was man sehen könnte ist
bei der produktion hier an dem
materiellen von weichteile geweben
befreiten knut sind so kleine kerben die
darauf hinweisen dass hier ein werkzeug
angewendet wurde möglicherweise zum
beispiel ein messer aber ganz allgemein
muss man sagen dass es entgegen der
landläufigen meinung ist
nicht sonderlich großen verletzungen
oder platzierungen bei der leiche kommt
ganz häufig sehen wir viele viele
befunde noch obwohl es lange gebrannt
hat und man muss sich auch vor augen
halten dass es das wissen wir aus
krematorien temperaturen von acht bis
900 grad bedarf und die leiche dann
mindestens eine halbe bis
dreiviertelstunde lang drin liegen wo es
erst dann ist damit zu rechnen dass man
nichts mehr sieht ansonsten sehen wir
sehr häufig verletzungen an den inneren
organen oder zum beispiel dem herz der
lunge oder den großen gefäßen aber auch
dem blut reichen organen in der leber
zum beispiel und das gibt uns ein
deutliche hinweise auf die todesursache
denn meistens ist die todesursache nach
stichverletzungen inneres verbluten auch
entsprechend viele große blutmengen
sehen wir dann in den körper höhlen in
der brusthöhle beispielsweise in der
bauchhöhle und in kombination mit den
fehlenden vitalen zeichen ist das dann
für uns ein sehr sicheres hinweise daten
sicherer hinweis dafür dass der tod eben
vor dem brandausbruch eingetreten ist
und dass wir es mit einem mottbrand zu
tun haben es war diese von unserer
expertin dr constantinis vielen dank
dass sie heute bei uns waren und
elf jahre liegt dieser mord an elisabeth
schmidt jetzt zurück doch noch immer so
viel ungeklärt die polizei wir haben es
gehört ermittelt weiter und benötigt
ihre hinweise und deshalb wollen wir sie
jetzt noch einmal zurück nehmen in diese
zeit in den dezember 2011
damals die wulff affäre durch eine wild
recherche zu seinem hauskredit gerät
bundespräsident christian wulff unter
druck später wird er zurücktreten
ein paar tage danach das
kreuzfahrtschiff costa concordia kennt
hat vor der insel jolo 32 menschen
sterben darunter 12 deutsche wenn sie
doch noch etwas wissen da melden sie
sich bei der polizei unter 0 39 41 67 42